rules and the incentives and politics
are all screwed up companies are usually
competing to try to succeed in politics
the parties are competing to benefit
themselves most of the people I talk to
they're just kind of thrown in the towel
saying I don't trust politicians and I
really don't want to do nothing about it
this is unacceptable
we have to change this what role do you
think universities and professors are
planned to send to a school to pay 50 to
70 grand a year knowing they're gonna
come out looking at rich people as bad
people this tremendous gap in wealth
capitalism haven't even any
responsibility for any of them you don't
think so how could you say that
competition delivers results to
customers in every industry we can't
just say here's what we're gonna do to
change the voting your question is are
they gonna let you do this we have a
choice voting in the state of Maine
we have ranchers voting on the ballot in
Massachusetts free-market politics a
politics which delivers what healthy
free markets deliver that's catchy that
makes sense to me more choice or voice
and better results
[Music]
you